come on them right thanks for taking the
pardoning spot you by the way of it yeah
no problem yeah surely Isabelle street
looking for a gaijin parking lot welcome
back to the gentleman yo yo how they're
looking for street parking scary well
you're gonna like our long time Sydney
all things competent by keeping their
cars come down i drive a car that looks
like a man trash cars you drive a mini
cooper yeah you drive a car that a
divorced woman in her forties it's the
video breath human yeah pick up the dry
cleaning today you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're 15 minutes late just apologize I
did apologize sorry I live on the west
side and our celebrities are trying to
commute out you live in a 600 square
foot apartment with four dogs and a
baker welcome back thank you take it
apart epub no problem jump on the street
which is the second one who's got the
second one huh which is a second spot
there's to all things comedy spots out
there we've got the second one probably
aren't hmm no let's get that [ __ ] toad
whoever that is well the reason i play
van Halen yeah why we have a very
special guest here today you've been
laid a bunch too by the way never never
if I'm late yeah within a minute or two
like no.2 1001 was I ever label
mariappan il-8 that be never would thank
you if I ever late when we were at the
other studio often that's bull 57
minutes late yeah almost 15 minutes late
yeah sorry well celebrity live in Santa
Monica where the celebrities with people
work on TV yeah they never been a loving
the 10 live right all aboot no no no i
live i live near uh maybe this sounds
familiar you live lagro yogurt fire haha
yeah okay we have a very special guest
here today oh we sure do you want to
introduce them no Steve's here wait a
minute how I guess oh yes we do Steve
by the way the last time I saw Steve
which when we did our little
anti-bullying campaign that's right yeah
that's was live from your backyard a
couple of weeks ago yeah yeah yeah that
was fun you really so that's I was not
late for that but i did get letters and
we did get comments after that saying
the son of the police cars did get in
the way of the feed from our street
Steve Simone how are you my friend good
buddy thanks for having on that swing
moment you also have a wonderful podcast
did he bring his own coffee cup it they
gave me this next door walk into the
wrong door what is your podcast as well
it's called good times good used to
being on it I want to have you back
yeahhh mister can I would love to have
you on whenever your schedule permits
does not permit but Steve is available
any type of the year to do your podcast
just throw it anyway I'm the reason that
we brought semonin today is because
we're on Rollins okay go Gary take over
well I listen to him over I'm excited I
would I love Steve yeah we're excited
first of all we're both wrestling fans
we love wrestling yeah but the reason we
brought Stephen is because all of us
including our buddy bill crawford who
works at DVD radio station in pittsburgh
yeah we're all going to do a big USO
tour in may yes we can't disclose the
location be awesome we can't talk look
at it yeah not now but but we are doing
a USO center OPSEC yeah and we are
talking about we could recollect about
our memories you have a great joke in
your act about coming back from a USO
tour why don't you do that you'll carry
received you really like this joke are
you measure with me because I think it's
one of my better jokes in my rolodex of
eight better than ever seen this guy get
mad have you ever seen you've gone for a
long I've never seen someone get mad
what what Aaron have never I've seen him
one time at The Comedy Store a purist
you remember the time I talked about now
somebody compared your act to Steve
Burns I'll [ __ ] I I have fans
all right okay oh that was okay yeah
Greg yeah yeah listen I don't have to be
on time I tell jokes when I give you my
very own I set the mood all you do is
mention where he's going to be yes good
to have you here Steve lovely to be I
wish you saw him at roast battle get
booed now have you ever seen a comic get
booed as a judge at rose battle no Gary
did not carry did oh yeah about the US
or they had to jump to roast battle they
called him a [ __ ] shut up I get a
piece of that uh when I came out strong
I came out hot hottie got really caught
I came out I went long it has to show
long and they all the audience turned on
them quick quick quickly yeah yeah yeah
real quick um anyways we're talking and
you have this great joke in your act
about how you're coming back from a USO
tour but you never did one and by the
way you did call me [ __ ] would you
like it if that was me I thought you
said you've ever done you a tour but you
say in your act a get do you get the
applause break please you want to like
you stayed in California you never got
on a plane to do a USO tour did you yes
we're years ago where I went with my
buddy Scott can wear to Iraq and
Afghanistan not that is a true sure why
would I make that up I do seriously
because I asked you about immigrant
before you like nine number one no I
could no no I did absolutely go years
ago when I won I won with scott kennedy
and julia Louis remember Julia ow she's
the best yeah yeah she was a navy girl
yeah she went up anymore the naval
academy she's like a genius yeah yeah
yeah yeah and you understand how people
go out on the road or do movies and hook
up because scott kennedy and i hooked up
you really actually did what i did i did
i actually went to Iraq and that is a
true story what I was checking in at the
United kiosk the woman's that are you
going to Iraq or Kuwait for business or
for pleasure and I was like oh wow
there's a new joke there there's one
right there so now i'm up to six fish
but you know I mean no I guess it's I
know he always good but no there's no
there's no finish to the joke well the
video well let me read that joke again
that's what you always say because they
never left that joke sucks I'm Simone
tell us about your anonymous to eat on
trellus without song
your personal tour all freaking you I
feel like this try playing video games
like mom or cheesy this feels like for
11 years old and it's just a bar what
year without Usher's like Owen without
the keyboard exactly the same thanks
exactly like without just cause you
don't laugh that means it's get you
nothing nothing nothing nobody laughs
Aaron's here is Simone's here right here
what year was your first USO or your
first trip overseas and who is it with
2006 was to Afghanistan through an
organization called comics on duty thank
you rich davis yeah the sweetest guy
ever who used to work for the USO and
then was like oh wait a second if I just
send comedians over they don't need a
stage they don't need an entourage they
don't it was like I can do way more
shows and bring comedy the places that
wouldn't get entertainment so he just
focused on bringing comedians and laughs
to the comics writer Dave's mischievous
who was an old-school Comedy Store guy
headed by that point when we landed in
Bagram they all knew Michelle it's like
he was in the milk game you're back he'd
probably done 20 tours by that time yeah
invited me to go along and it was the
best experience I've ever had in common
was Dave like the scott kennedy could
Scott did a tour like every angle month
yeah he was out there all the time he
would come back and then just jump right
back out again yep how does a guy like
because I know rich davis Russia maison
who ya did a lot of those tours that's
how I became such good buddies with
maison because the next tour was with
him we did for t-day we did we were gone
40 days 40 days 40 days it was insane
where were you guys going well the first
tours Afghanistan and the second tour
like I it was like you want to go to
Europe I was like yes but then when we
were in Europe then they took us to
Bahrain for Navy to actually do actual
ships so say we did it towards like four
guys in Europe then three of us went to
the Persian Gulf right or what do they
call the Arabian Sea you ever notice
that guys in the Navy they call it the
Arabian Sea I'm like that must be the
official term and then it's audley
cutter yeah exactly and then two of us
got extended they're like
a man if you guys could stick around a
couple more days there's a whole
aircraft carrier fleet that's going to
be coming in volume i have and i was
like better then they flew us out i
think i think that was the eisenhower we
did while some of the little ships
around I've done three aircraft on the
aircraft carrier yes oh wow so it's like
staying on the Millennium Falcon yes I
feel like you feel like you're on a
spaceship it's the coolest thing ever
they treat us so well that did it's
almost what an hour is almost it's so
ironic because you're there to express
gratitude for every they do and they're
like rolling out the red carpet likes
thank you think it's like no no we're
here to thank you guys yeah that's
already knew it I'd be happy yeah that's
it's the whole reason to do it it also
go over there and say thank you face it
wait a minute well I asked Gary I go hey
you want to do this ruse so Tori he goes
absolutely how much do I get paid and
I'm like you know yeah that's what my
first question yeah how I get paid
because I don't leave the country or the
state unless I'm getting you know I'm
your stipend I would have so much work
here in town that it's not worth it for
me yeah oh you're take you to walk or
you walk your dogs and pick up all their
[ __ ] and that's why you're late today
take up dog [ __ ] you're picking up dog
[ __ ] that white that's why you're late
by the way these soldiers thanks tea
before the show it's never after they
think and before then after the show
they're like hey we'd rather go to the
front lines [ __ ] gary said you only
comics that the soldiers come out and
applaud as the planes taking off you
know what don't use that Joe can I use
that new you just on your Facebook page
I said that to you I did read did I not
just tell me read today did I just say
gary said that I thought you did about
Steve well you owe to me that's the only
time did the soldiers applaud when
Steve's leaving select the bucket will
stay here we'll stay here enough na ho
yeah what was the most what was the
coolest thing you've got to do while
you're on a USO tour and what was the
most danger you've been in while your
honor us or I I should stop saying
yourself but as you're entering any
trips your arm well look I honestly I
think the coolest thing is those
conversations you have with
people in uniform where you could be so
far away from home but because of either
the anticipation before the show or the
show itself or that feeling that gets
left in the air right when you stay and
talk to them afterwards and you don't
feel like you're in Iraq or Afghanistan
yeah on some ship where you feel as I
can you feel like you literally feel
like you're back at the comedy store
yeah and it's the greatest thing ever
for that time you're there hanging out
with those guys it you're not at war
it's incredible I think that's honestly
the coolest thing it could it literally
feels different you know what I'm saying
like yeah because like when you're going
on tour and you're seeing like all the
stuff they do you like all Mike what am
I doing here this is like a war is going
on then you do your comedy show and it's
just a show yeah i think that feeling is
the coolest thing I've ever felt um but
in terms of experiences on the aircraft
carriers they let us be down on the
flight deck when I took off and you have
like two or three sets of things on your
ears there's a Top Gun theme song going
through your head it is a great if
you're like this is why Ronnie jco made
music like because it's just so insane
and then we did I forget which carrier
was but like the fighter pilots are like
the like if it's a floating high school
they're the football team but guys
they're only order Beck's yes and they
loved us yeah so they like bro and they
started to tell their stories about
growing up with brothers or whatever was
so then they were like have you ever
seen night landings I'm like what are
you talking about and it's these little
observation decks around the carrier
where they have to judge how the guys
land like that's such a hot I don't
there to window to be next to a puss
impossible to go on and dark yeah yeah
and they're doing it in the dark but if
even if they do it they only have three
attempts even if they do it on their
first attempt if the like the angle
they're coming in at is not the right
one right they can lose their job so
they brought us out on these decks
floating off kind of off the ship and
having the planes fly in over top of us
so that and I'm like this is you get to
do things at north
the greatest thing ever yeah when I was
a guy Africa you know we were someone
the Middle East and we got to UM I don't
I should say it but but but they let us
there like you want to shoot the gun
we're a Blackhawk I'm like uh yeah I
love to shoot the gun and they go okay
so you stand there and there's a turret
you know it's just hanging out you know
in this Bay and the guy goes just shoot
the sand check it out and so you shoot
the sand and you see the sparks because
the sand is so hot the bullets so hot
that it looks like just like these
little flames are wow great and I go I
go can I take my shirt off he goes no
you can't take you cuz Rambo I always
had that dream I like Rambo ah it's the
muscles and I was a malaria and oh yeah
I wanted to accept a Styrofoam that was
selfish but I agree with you it's the
Hang that's the best part is greater
when you get to go to the mess hall and
just eat with everybody and see people
that you did to show the night before
and I just want to hang out and gray and
they all want to tell you stories yeah
and their stories are awesome the
greater Gary what about you I like
cheeseburgers no I will tell you that
here's what's crazy i agree with you
what was like even even what the i like
jeez burgers huh I'm hungry um but
here's what I was out you look I bring
the comedic value entertainment that's a
side of it no here's right will tell you
you know was great I don't know if you
ever did this gig but uh Brad Williams
and I did a gig that was off the coast
of San shot I'm into it well you really
into it I've you mother Goose of storage
Ella nope do you ever do that gig where
it's right up the coast of Santa Barbara
and you fool you actually go up to
Oxnard you carry out a headliner he
doesn't pick up the AC rooms rooster t
feathers that what you're talking about
what the you who room in burbank
pleasure what we like it makes it like
opening for brother what is the point of
this story we're talking about it is
your gig yes scary maybe not my best day
I came out swinging
almost like roast panel and I came out
strong dip it a little bit okay very
early yeah here on Isabel street yeah
with no parking that what was what was
what was the best part what was the most
redemptive asset that you felt of doing
the the sherbet or for the mill for the
military well I got you know the crazy
thing is in Steve you I mean you hit on
this it's it's literally that line right
it's like you just got married and
there's a line of a hundred soldiers men
and women waiting to meet you and again
it's the craziest thing because they're
coming over saying thank you thank you
thank you for what you just did yeah and
you know I mean listen I was with scott
kennedy who have been over there a bunch
of times Julia it was her an I first
time I mean you look people are coming
over and wanting pictures and you're
assigning these autographs you're like
this seems so ridiculously silly because
obviously you're there for them you
don't mean a real hero and what I love
about it you nailed this Steve there are
so many things in life that you know we
get to do as comics that nobody can ever
do and I not the coolest thing was it
didn't matter how much money you had or
whatever you wanted to do you couldn't
do that as a regular civilian no way you
could have done that absolutely and
being in comedy you were able to do that
you were able to go over there and be
part of this we did you have people in
the military don't even get to do right
like yeah let's spend our whole life in
the Navy may never landed on an aircraft
carrier in on a black hawk well he
doesn't for when I went the very last
time my brother a stationed at Camp
Victory north Wow he talked to his
commanding officer and he got the day
off so he was able to travel with us and
it was me Colin Quinn and Robert Kelly
how cool is that and so you know it's
surreal seeing your little brother and
he's like got his gun he's got his
sidearm he's in camo he's a soldier yeah
it's like oh this is my little brother
he can take me out any man so wish you
would we thought having flashbacks
anyways um he I was telling him he's
like how did you get into the camp and I
was like oh we we got in on a Blackhawk
he's like son of a [ __ ] yeah he's like
I've been in the military for four years
I never got to take a blackhawk yeah and
so yeah you're you know you kind of I
guess
you don't know any better though right
but you do take it for granted the
c-130s when you flying those huge cargo
oh it's so cool and it's just you and
like two other comics and then you have
this enormous cargo plane just they're
just transporting you it's in kaminey
thousand tens of thousands of dollars in
fuel or operating cause damn take but
that's what they do to provide
entertainment for these guys and gals
well it is crazy though too because you
do realize very quickly talking to the
soldiers that they don't have a lot
going on out there there's not much time
I think it really is you know when they
do find out that there's a comedy show
coming up there so thrilled because it's
just something I mean they're you're
behind those four walls every day well
you can only place they have those rec
centers work yeah you can only play so
much xbox or have access to every movie
possible until you just want to do
something else okay this is what
happened to me just recently so probably
two weeks ago this hat I'm wearing now
there's a company called Ranger up it's
owned by all our current or former Army
Rangers which are like the superheroes
there so I love to support the military
and veterans any way I can clusters MMA
fighter named tim kennedy that's one of
the owner he's like my hero oh yeah so
I'm like and i can buy an american flag
hat awesome it's like win-win-win and so
I was wearing it at the gym once in the
sky was like are you in the middle I'm
like no I I got the hat because I do
these USO tours I'm a comedian he was
like what oh my god that's incredible
he's like I'm a Marine I'm like thank
you and he's like no thinking I'm like
ysis guys so happy that we do what we do
because I mean all I stand in all what
they do and we could I think we should
talk about that at some point yeah but
anyway so that was like say two weeks
ago like three days after that I get a
text from a buddy of mine who I'd met on
that first tour in Afghanistan yes so I
met somebody in Afghanistan we stayed in
touch through the years anyway I shut up
now what I saw you looking over your
insert gay joke here I know I saw he was
waiting don't I was wondering what
Simone was doing at the gym wait go
I lost me hello this is all alive so she
needed a place to crash and I'm like
yeah dude you can crash for a night I
could like you want to say thank you
right yeah so I was like and I told him
the story and he was like because what
you guys do mean so much I'm like what
are you talking about he's like in his
opinion this is just one person that
served he was he felt that so many
people don't care right that there's
this mentality that they're out there
literally putting their lives on the
lines and so many people don't don't
appreciate what they do right he's like
so when a civilian takes time out of
their schedule to come over there and
say thank you it means what we do
matters I'd oh yeah whoa and then he had
brought up what we were just talking
about it goes you have no idea what a
gift that is because when you guys are
on stage we're not at war yeah I means
like you can't because you can't put a
price on that I remember oh five i went
with drew carey and this is like and
you're if you're there in 06 it's
probably like you know right there at
the peak of everything in them oh yeah
three maybe four or five six it's all
like you know it's prevalent in the news
and what ya know worried we have four
operating bases and everything and I was
sharing the front and I remember I did
this show and was with Drew Carey and I
finished my set and this kid comes up to
me goes you don't know what this means I
know what he goes I literally he and he
was saying how surreal it was how he was
in this firefight because this convoy
had gotten ambushed and so they went in
to rescue the convoy and they got it a
firefight and they're dragging bodies
and then like he just comes back to the
base he's walking to his barracks and he
hears people laughing and he comes over
and he goes Nixon oh I'm laughing he's
like I was just and I think he was
trying to process it to where yeah I'll
never forget him I like I can picture
him to this day but he was saying how I
was just shooting at people and trying
to rescue and people and now I'm here
and I'm like you guys made me for
get about things for a few and so thank
you and I was like it was like surreal
to see I when when else do you do a
comedy show it never matters that much
like I never realized being at a meeting
with anything like I never realized that
it mattered and I mean so many ways it
doesn't matter what we do but in those
instances yeah you do Mike oh I I can I
can contribute to it was the first time
I really felt that and I got addicted to
that feeling because like I'm like oh I
just want to help how can I help oh I
can help by being funny or you or is
well then whenever you need me I'm here
whenever how about you Gary and
experiences of soldiers you got to talk
to before after do you still keep in
touch with Drew Carey maybe each on the
price is right when some appliances for
Jess gary was he's executing her I'm
back baby no but it is it's remember we
did a show it was a small show I mean
and you know this sometimes the smallest
shows in the back to the best shows
because I remember me Scott Julia got to
one of the bases it was ten in the
morning and there were six people there
and something was going on a lot of the
other soldiers had to go and do
something so there were like six or
seven of us and or six or seven soldiers
that were there so Scott's kind of
mentality was like hey it's almost a
small group why don't we just go around
and just talk to them and you know
socializes and everything and we all
kind of agreed like hey they're here
they want to show let's do it yep and
sometimes those shows for like six
people are the greatest of all time
because they're so engaged well they
have to be for you well I mean it gave
me the experience to now deal with your
tour which was great oh you know you
don't get that many but it was crazy
that that little group and I remember
doing a show one time in a little church
o our standing next to this huge cross
and you're like can I drop the f-bomb
and he right there like you can do
whatever you
want it was just weird like I mean back
then I did all different material than I
do not but like it just seeing that
cross there was the weirdest thing ever
all different to be material yeah yeah I
mean good um Wow well I will say yeah i
agree with you this small we did this
this Forward Operating Base head of s I
mean we were I think we were like we
were literally like three miles away
from I think the Iranian border yeah and
we got flu in in a Blackhawk we land in
the middle of like it was almost like it
was almost like this desert /
mountainside whatever but it looked like
a bombed-out building yeah we're stage
we just land there and we walk into this
base this building was bombed out yeah
it looked like something you'd see I'm
like Saving Private Ryan or something in
the desert so we we go in and there are
maybe 30 guys beards yeah yoked they all
look like Abercrombie models with beards
the attitudes I wouldn't none of them
were below 64 yeah 220 just jacked
strapped walk it was like the most
intimidating I'm walking in with I i
think was Drew Carey I was with true
carrion to add Schubert was there
awesome and two other comics and we walk
in we're like what are we doing here
like all right get to it yeah we go up
the best show the gray obably the best
show I've ever done in my life start to
finish not only being a part of but
witnessing drew a hitting the ground
running these guys must have been
firefight in a firefight for other real
days and marooned out there just stuck
out there you know they had to had a hot
meal and honks hadn't had a shower
probably longer than that yeah and you
it was just like a gasket blew they just
needed the greatest the relay discov
laughter one of the best things that
ever happened to me on one of these
tours happened years after the tour I
was in San Diego maybe a year ago a year
and a half ago and I was talking to this
guy who is a commune
and it just came up he was like well
then I went on the GI Bill and like oh
thank you for your service here second
no one so we started to talk and he was
like it was actually in the military I
was inspired to become a comedian I'm
like no way was like ow stations in
Afghanistan we're at a little combat
outpost and he was like a helicopter
lands and everybody's like adjust for
comedians get off the helicopter and I'm
like whoa I things like wasn't anybody I
recognized it wasn't anybody famous but
it was so cool that they were there and
he was like most of them weren't that
funny and I was like if they can do it I
can do it I'm like wait when was I we
saw that I was one of the comedians well
that he had seen and he was like all my
god that was the last time I went to
Afghanistan and he was like it inspired
him to start doing comedy like this the
circles complete this is the craziest
thing ever we did at that time to where
we were coming off a helicopter and then
we passed three other comics that were
jumping on to a plane like you're
passing and like it's you're seeing this
other group of comics that you know from
LA yeah and you're just passing in the
wind if they're heading somewhere else
it's like were thousands and thousands
of miles away so they're heading to a
different base it's very crazy you know
that you're it and when you're up on
those stages you don't you don't really
realize where you are you mean you'll
realize that you're you're in an active
war zone yeah well I'd I will say the
only time I ever realized I'm not on a
normal stage is in 04 mm we go out to
this courtyard in in like the city
somewhere and there's a flatbed truck
with camel on and stuff and it's just
little courtyard really really small but
they had a flatbed truck there and
there's maybe 30 40 chairs set up and
all these soldiers sitting in it and
because i was young i was i'm seeing the
show so i went at first and i walk over
and I'm like above the stage in this
building there's a sniper there's two
snipers yeah and I go uh what does that
guy was because there was a guy there
and there was a guy over on this side I
go and I was like looking around like
why are there slippers
up on the thing and they go those
snipers are there looking at the snipers
way off over there yeah I'm like why are
we doing the show here I should we be
inside yeah but they put the show
outside and that was the most scared
I've ever been in my entire life doing
stand-up knowing i really thought I'm
gonna get shot I really believe but I
was like well that's why we're their
lair they're like I ever my mom was like
putting it and I was like mom imagine
you're 18 years old and you're scared
I'm like those kids are sick my job is
to give them a relief from that feeling
you know feel that 24 hours a day I
don't think like I I always have an
appreciation for people that serve
always but then when you actually go and
see the sacrifices up close and I just
literally stand in awe well sorry just
the sacrifice of like the profession
it's the sacrifice of these are sons
daughters yeah others father's yes these
are birthdays miss ya the holidays
missed these are a two year old kid not
being there for Christmas with his mom
or dad oh that's the real like personal
sacrifice not only you know and then
that worried were like every day they're
like this could be my last day that's
part of their job yeah they're willing
to die for this country know when you
stop and think about that is just
nothing more heroic than that data my
last tour through Afghanistan I don't
know what year it was was like 2013
maybe 2014 and we're at one of the
little combat outposts I remember like
and I just got a bad feeling because you
start to realize like oh this is real
and then we went to another base that
was bigger I forget it was a little bit
was a fob because I don't know I'm not a
military guy but it was a bigger base
yeah and I'm like dude I don't not have
a good feeling you know they had to shut
down that base because the people that
we were training
turned on the people that were training
them and killed two of our elders so
they had to shut down the whole days and
you're like oh this is this is real yeah
and on that same tour one of the shows
was cancelled because the guys that were
building our stage took a shell so
literally hit the stage we were supposed
to perform on the following day she's
real yeah it's also interesting to when
you're out there there's no talk of
politics there's no who were in favor of
who or not I mean like it's very like
everybody is just out their job that's
what I loved about it and one of my
favorite moments to was I think was one
of the last days that we were out there
we were I think we were back in Kuwait
and a bunch of the wounded warriors from
the wounded warriors program got to go
up and do stand-up oh that's awful late
they'll stand up in just this amazing
supportive room like like I think six
guys went up and did it lets the six
more guys you could open for really see
them talk about the wounded warriors and
that's how you turn it see cheeseburger
but it's a very cool just to see them go
up there and do what it was just awesome
it's amazing actually there's an
organization called a awaken arts where
it there they work with guys that are
working through PTSD and I use art as
therapy for that and one of the things
that I want to do is a we could do that
with stand-up we could to any guy that
has an interest in may be doing stand-up
we could sort of mentor them through the
process yeah I think that would be the
coolest thing ever well they tried to
how comics what's that they'd want to
talk to comics so you're out anywho uh
yeah i agree with you i mean there are
moments when you're over there where you
realize how real it truly is i remember
i was going on the c-130 which is those
huge cargo planes and they asked two of
us if they wanted to if we wanted to sit
up in the cockpit yeah and you put on
the headset you can hear everything that
they're communicating back and forth and
it's all
technical jargon and now I have no idea
what they're saying but we're going up
and I see fireworks and I was like oh
it's pretty cool no I just naive it's
just yeah those are fireworks that's
pretty cool maybe they're doing a show
for the troops or whatever right we land
and those are heat-seeking flares
because an RPG was shot at us at the
c-130 yes and so those flares trickled
down and the-the-the are the Rockets
would follow the flares as opposed to
the they did that when we were in a Iraq
the last time that's right yeah and now
how we took than the flares went off
yeah and I was like is anybody else
getting nervous physics and then we
landed yeah and I'm like we weren't
supposed to land what's good and what
happens yeah I think that might have
been a prank for us but I don't think
they crank I don't think that they I
like up with it I'm like we weren't even
in danger there yeah I haven't lamp
let's just see which of these four is
going to [ __ ] their pants like well it
is funny how the military datejust
nobody just even cracks like everybody
just like hey this is commonplace
there's no they make you feel very
comfortable because they're not damaging
yeah they're the cooler yeah they just
lay low and it just you know but it is
weird when you're doing a show and every
single audience member has a machine gun
on their back you're just like what's
going on here better be funny yeah yeah
I remember doing a show in Djibouti once
and which was a really cool base because
it was all branches of the military were
there everybody and then I didn't
realize that that was probably like all
pretty much like special operators and
stuff like that because its proximity to
Somalia what I remember doing the show
and I don't know about you guys but if I
don't have a good show at the comedy
store I don't care yeah but if I don't
have a good show entertaining the troops
I almost can't live with it like I feel
like yeah I had my super power to make
somebody laugh and I couldn't do it you
know what I mean like I I love those
guys so much that I feel like it's the
only time we're like you literally give
them every
you possibly can to make them laugh and
I remember to watch ever do that crazy
comedian thing where you're like wait
there's that guy that one's eyes not
laughing yo I can watch that like so
this was probably I don't know eight
years ago I was a younger comic and the
first guy goes up and killing but the
one guys might have then the next guy
goes up everybody's killing but there's
just one dude that's just sitting there
with his legs cross from his arms
crossed and he look like he had seen
some he look like a modern-day pirate
yeah like nobody's sitting near this
dude he had the eyes he had bent and I
remember when I was up on stage I
remember him starting to laugh and it
looked like he was turning into like a
werewolf or something cuz he was trying
to fight it yes and seeing a look on his
face like as he was laughing he almost
didn't know what he was doing with yeah
it is yeah we had forgotten how to laugh
so then that guy trying to get it easier
and you know when somebody loves it and
they make eye contact with the person
next time like isn't it did you I've
done that like the positive heckles and
I remember hanging out with that guy
after the show and he was like oh guys
were awesome this was the best time I've
had normally the show sucked but you
guys were really good and I was like oh
this was the whole reason why are you
doing yeah well it's awesome i'm excited
to work with you guys yeah we're in a
three built craw feel Crawford we're
going to head back out yeah mid-may for
what 10 days 7 10 day 7 days or so yeah
thank you so much for giving me the
opportunity I'm so glad you're coming
cuz you're I know you appreciate it so
great on and when you do during now you
are your joke will actually make sense
when you do the USO tour how much do you
sell your merch fortuna soldier here we
go do you give them a soldier discount
go alright Justin more for Simone floor
bombing more bombing what do you-- total
by the way in reference to steve Simone
he must not care a lot at the comedy
store then I play the outro Steve
parking was a [ __ ] today too yeah it's
for Simone okay the most the biggest van
Halen
yeah I've ever met in my life so we
cannot psych you Simone thank you that
you let me hang out good time yeah well
i have a new CD out called what's up
nerds by the way i blasted it out I
downloaded it I have it it's awesome and
I i was just talking my wife the other
day about your willy wonka run gave me
an literally one of my favorite [ __ ]
I've never because I was watching this
the other day with my daughter you got
it look just download Steve Simone one
of the best thank you literally one of
my favorites yeah f we love this guy
where's your album is available which
one which we are witch one the platinum
one what are they called that one's
called up plenty of tickets available
this deeper newer can i fire Simone
awesome Steve calm calm calm Gary Steve
you'll be F celebrate improv next
weekend and I saw that little email that
they sent out about get on your guest
list really the date normally Saturday
first shows never a freebie which looks
like it was for this one yep any dates
all dates all tickets available just
come up to the box office mumble
anything you'll get right in mumble
anything alright we are the gentleman's
dub just extra listening and thank you
to all the men and women who have or are
currently serving our country we look
forward to in Greenburgh has said it god
bless the USA
[Music]
haha